The Curious Case of Alien Hand Syndrome
Although modern medicine has made tremendous
advances in many areas, even mapping the human
genome, there remain aspects of human health
that continue to elude our full understanding.
Alien hand syndrome is one of these puzzles-
with its sufferers having one of their hands,
usually the non-dominant one, acting as if
it has a mind of its own.
Many of us have seen people with this condition,
albeit on the big screen.
In the campy 1935 horror film, Mad Love, deranged
surgeon Peter Lorre replaces a pianist’s
hands with those of a knife-throwing murderer,
and the hands take over.
More recently and more well known, in Dr.
Strangelove or: How I Learned to Stop Worrying
and Love the Bomb(1964), Peter Sellers in
the eponymous role repeatedly and compulsively
fights to keep his right arm from striking
a Nazi salute.
(In fact, the syndrome is also sometimes called
“Dr. Strangelove Syndrome”.)
Yet what’s entertaining and even hilarious
in the theater is not nearly so funny in real
life.
Inconveniently and often embarrassingly touching,
pinching and pulling, these alien hands may
compulsively grasp a breast or stroke a penis
while the person it’s attached to rides
the subway or waits in line; there are also
potential legal ramifications if the hand
strays to others in such an inappropriate
fashion.
Described by scientists as a “complex, goal-directed
activity in one hand that is not voluntarily
initiated,” sufferers from the disorder
are aware of the movement, and they feel what
the hand feels, but often feel as if they
have no control over it.
Almost always occurring on the non-dominant
side (i.e., if you’re right handed, your
alien hand would be your left), many patients
with this condition get to the point where
they refer to the hand as if it is another
person, even giving it a different name.
Frequently, suffers may complain, “I can’t
make it listen to me.”
Symptoms range from compulsively grasping
and releasing an object to fully self-oppositional
movements, like stubbing out a cigarette immediately
after the other hand has lit it or unbuttoning
a shirt as the other hand buttons.
In between the extremes, some suffers can
control the arm with great effort, although
even then, their movements may be imprecise;
for example, while trying to touch the tip
of the nose, they touch the shoulder instead.
Extreme cases have occurred where the hand
has attacked, and even tried to strangle with
a cord, the person to which it’s attached.
The syndrome itself is one of a number of
similar conditions, each thought to be the
product of some type of brain trauma or injury.
The most common, or at least most well documented,
cases of alien hand syndrome involve epileptics
who have voluntarily undergone a procedure
to separate the left and right hemispheres
of the brain in an effort to control their
seizures; however, it has been known to occur
in people who suffered from a brain tumor,
stroke, infection or aneurysm.
There is no known cure for this condition,
though it can usually be controlled somewhat
by giving the alien hand something to do,
like having it hold a cane while you are in
public, so the hand stays occupied.
A similar, and likewise bizarre, condition
is known as Body Integrity Identity Disorder
(BIID), which appears to be purely psychological.
People suffering with this condition also
feel as if one of their limbs is not really
a part of themselves.
But rather than live with it, they have a
very strong desire to have the offending limb
amputated.
As psychiatrists describe it, the “motivation
for the preferred body modification is believed
to be a mismatch between actual and perceived
body schema.”
Not included in the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders IV (DSM-IV), most
with this condition receive little to no formal
treatment; rather, many take matters into
their own hands: For instance, in one case
reported by TheGuardian when the man in question
“was just out of college, he’d tried to
[amputate his leg] using a tourniquet fashioned
out of an old sock and strong baling twine…
After two hours the pain was unbearable, and
fear sapped his will.
The leg was always there as a foreign body,
an imposter, an intrusion.
He spent every waking moment imagining freedom
from the leg.
. . . The leg just wasn’t his.
He began to blame it for keeping him single…”
Another BIID sufferer had more success when
he shot his leg.
As he said, “I’ve wanted to be one-legged
since I was a child . . . . No one can help
this overwhelming and irrational wish that
I’ve experienced with varying degrees for
as long as I can remember.
For the first time in my life, I’m finally
happy.”
In a 2005 study, it was found that of 52 BIID
sufferers interviewed, 9 had a limb amputated
and six of those used “methods that put
the subject at risk of death.”
Perhaps even more disturbingly, three had
been able to find a surgeon willing to amputate
a healthy limb; in fact, in the 1990s, Dr.
Robert Smith of the Farkirk Royal Infirmary
in Scotland performed at least two such surgeries
before news of them became public.
Another surgeon, who had lost his license
years before, performed an illegal amputation
of a healthy limb in Tijuana in 1998, but,
sadly, the patient died of gangrene.
Today, there is apparently a surgeon somewhere
in Asia who, for $6,000, will sneak a BIID
sufferer into his hospital and perform an
emergency amputation while pretending to do
another surgery.